[Applause]
oh dude
we got people shooting us verses i want
to like read some of the verses
do some fire verses because we couldn't
rhyme waldorf what
oh do you have one of them okay this is
somebody went in
and they we have two versions where they
went in they're nice as [ __ ] with you
know beats or whatever and they started
creating a song this is one version
i don't know who the [ __ ] made it but
thank you
uh
[Music]
tricking on a tall horse oh with the
tall heart you know what i mean we're
tricking on these tall
horse where's where's meg the stallion
when you need her bro we're tricking on
these tall horses
hit bits on all fours whoa
[ __ ] in the waldorf tricking on the
tall horse got the [ __ ] on all fours
maybe there's three because one of them
kind of might be a little shot
what do you mean one was a little shot
three al jesus
christ we're such a good why are you
trying to make rap music about violence
dude
yeah you guys are always [ __ ] in the
world the lit [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the wall door okay tricking
on a tall horse
that's what's happening got the bits on
all fours all fours
what's happening next bruh that's where
you come in
do one bar you're the black guy
there's no balls yet thank you said i
take it too violet [ __ ]
she squirts and we mop up floors it's
okay
i mean rearrange it i just felt this
jewelry he's like we have to clean
it was okay he said something sexual and
immediately went to clean it up
afterwards he couldn't even enjoy the
squirt
as the squirt is coming out i can see
him in his head like with a girl
a girl squirting on her sheets seemed
like oh my god i'll have to take these
in
i just try clothes i actually have a
strategy for that what is that
if it's like at a hotel like you request
a rule
ready for the strategy got the bits on
all fours
get a room with two beds ah that doesn't
rhyme it doesn't run no
i meant the strategy for that
come on eat the ass like old dwarves
i saw he was gone
it would
[Music]
oh eat the ass call it hors d'oeuvres
oh it's a hors d'oeuvre am i broke
i thought that was pretty good he was
actually he felt that way you were
completely off today jesus
you just got it young you got swaggered
out that's how you sold [ __ ] in the
wall
[ __ ] in the wall tricking on the tall
horse bang bang got the chick on all
fours
eat the acid corn doors
don't disrespect bro takashi don't
disrespect the goat bro
don't disrespect me putting my rap
skills on him but we will have you on
this podcast
takashi if you're still doing bar shows
in orlando and you want to
stop that you want to change your life
we're here to change our shows in
orlando you want to open her holler at
your boys is going to open for takashi
let's go i like that tour he tried to
stage dive and fell straight to the
floor did he no
no no no he didn't look like he fell
looked like that she looked fired
he felt sick i don't think he felt like
his security rush
i don't think he fell bro i think alex
is hating bro yeah alex why are you
happy
i know why you hanging because you ain't
got no [ __ ] in the waldorf door
you're gonna finish that versa fire yo
we're gonna get takashi on that
[ __ ] it's in the wall door
[ __ ] in the wall door checking on a
tall horse got the chicken all for us
what's the last one like oh dork
[Laughter]
hors d'oeuvres but hors d'oeuvres
doesn't rhyme at all they should like
hors d'oeuvres
but that doesn't rhyme we need eminem
it's a slant rhyme dog you know what i
mean
whoa dude stop aging hey